good morning john it's been quite a week
and i i spent a lot of time
looking at a google doc trying to like
come back from your
very good very emotional video and have
something
deep and profound to say but i'm a
little too overwhelmed for it right now
so that was the thing of what do i like
to do
i like to share knowledge i like to
learn things and so i tweeted what's
your best fact
and then i read through over 900 replies
to that tweet and i have selected for
you
the best facts according to me let's
start with some good evolutionary
history action because sharks
have been around for longer than trees
which is something considering that as
dr
steve points out also trees aren't a
thing they're a strategy for survival
not a taxonomic group honorable mention
shark fact there are individual sharks
that are alive today
that were born before my country existed
best music fact
gotta be that dolly parton wrote jolene
and i will always love you
on the same car trip she was like
driving by herself and wrote the songs
can you imagine
being in that car an extra good fact
because it contains the surprise fact
that yeah dolly parton wrote i will
always love you
second fiddle to that though uh has to
be the original lyrics to yesterday by
the beatles scrambled
[Music]
i eggs your legs not as much as i love
scrambled eggs
oh we should eat some
scrambled eggs it's like they wrote the
weird owl version of their
own song first best movie fact i'm sorry
just viggo broke his foot i know we all
know it but vigo broke his foot speaking
of feet though this one blew my mind the
majority of the bones in the human body
are in the hands and feet
unless the person is pregnant in which
case the majority of the bones in the
human body are in the uterus because
babies
have more bones than adults look i don't
like it either which leads to a broader
category of fact that i really like
which is facts that
are definitely true even though they
definitely seem not true like that the
average person has an above average
number of legs other facts in this
category include the fact that you
were once the youngest person on earth
and that every day there is a person who
has the biggest
poo but they will never know it was them
i like this one a lot the second largest
purchaser of explosives in the us
is the happiest place on earth and
speaking of explosions if
the earth moon system survives the
expansion of the sun into a red giant
which like it might not but if it does
then like 60 billion-ish years after
that happens
the moon will crash into the earth and
destroy whatever was left here so it's
coming at us from all angles like space
is a dangerous place on
long time scales gotta throw one history
effect in here and it's gotta be that
there is a chance that charlemagne was
killed by his tablecloth
which was made of asbestos and he loved
it because he could clean it by throwing
it into a fire john
our second to last fact is the best fact
as voted
by people who clicked the like button on
the tweet and it is that
arctic comes from the greek word for
near the bear
thus antarctic kind of means not near
the bear and there are no bears in
antarctica and there are lots of them in
the arctic but i have to add an addendum
fact to this because this is not why we
named them this it's a coincidence
the arctic is near the bear because of
ursa major
the constellation in the sky above the
arctic the bear that the arctic is near
is barely a bear at all
it's a dipper but john the number one
fact in my judgment the one that i liked
the most because i did not know it
and i have believed the lie my whole
life is that fingers don't get pruny
because like the water absorbs the oils
out of them or whatever you've been told
your whole life because if nerves to the
fingers get cut
they don't get pruning anymore it's not
a physical reaction
it's a neurological one our bodies are
intentionally
making our fingers wrinkly probably so
that we don't slip when we're in the
water
why didn't anybody tell me this who was
gonna tell me
everybody thank you for sending in facts
on twitter john congrats on the book
release and i'll see you on tuesday
scrambled eggs